in the heyday of the ds and 3ds nintendo
dedicated itself to a blue ocean
strategy of attracting a wider audience
than traditional gamers headlining this
effort were games like brain age and big
brain academy puzzle games targeted
toward non-gamers that promised regular
mental exercises to stay sharp and
enhance your focus more than a decade
later big brain academy brain versus
brain recenters itself around nintendo's
new strategic priority social features
and competition and while the puzzles in
brain versus brain work just as well as
ever the competition aspect is an
awkward fit that runs counter to a game
series that has always been friendly and
non-judgmental the main appeal of these
brain training games has always been to
run your own race chipping away at daily
exercises with big brain academy's
fictional dr loeb lets you see the
progression of slow steady improvement
as you sharpen your mental acuity in
previous games over the course of a week
or a month or even several months the
improvement would get more consistent
and you could see yourself getting
smarter or at least better at these
particular gamified skills brain vs
brain is centered around competition and
feels a little less approachable for it
[Music]
that's not to say the game itself shames
you dr loeb is as positive and
encouraging as ever always couching weak
spots in gentle terms and nudging you to
spend more time practicing any fields
where you didn't excel but when you
create a puzzle game ostensibly about
measuring intelligence and then player
against both friends and a worldwide
gaming audience it's going to be fertile
ground for planting self-doubt big brain
academy brain vs brain measures your
competency in five categories identify
memorize analyze compute and visualize
each consisting of four exercises the
line between those categories can be
fuzzy the shadow shift game which has
you pick out silhouetted shapes is
grouped in the visualized category when
it could easily fit into identify for
example each exercise ramps up the
difficulty as you complete phases of it
on a timer adding both more elements and
complexities to those elements by the
time you reach the top few ranks you may
need to sit and think for several
moments some exercises become downright
inscrutable at least in the final few
seconds you have remaining on the clock
[Music]
your single player options are limited
to practice an unlockable super practice
mode that starts the exercises at a
higher difficulty and the holistic test
function the test is meant to show your
aptitude across all five categories by
serving them up one at a time resulting
in a pentagon shaped spider chart with
sharper spikes in the fields where you
excelled the idea is to give an easy
visualization of where you're doing best
and where you could stand to improve and
it does that well when i first started i
was extremely lopsided toward memorize
and away from compute which squared with
my own understanding of my strengths and
weaknesses after some practice i made
the graph roughly more symmetrical which
is ultimately the goal to brush up on
weaker spots so you're well balanced
across the disciplines that said it's
not an exact science the test function
plucks one of each category's exercises
at random and after practicing there
were still some exercises that i just
didn't connect with very well even in a
category i felt comfortable with there
would inevitably be an exercise i
struggled with if one of these weaker
exercises happened to be the one that
came up during a test it would throw off
my entire score and the test would be a
wash similarly some games are especially
brutal at burning your clock which can
impact your score the higher levels of
fast focus a game that slowly reveals a
picture to you takes so long to reveal
anything even potentially recognizable
that it can be maddening watching the
time take away
[Music]
you can brush up on these skills in
practice mode by taking on one event at
a time that helped but sometimes i would
find myself frustrated by the timer
suddenly pulling the plug on an exercise
some of the more advanced exercises take
more time to think through and by the
time i reached one i wouldn't have
enough time to invest in it before it
abruptly ended the get in shape puzzles
for instance have you build increasingly
complex shapes out of small parts and i
would have liked the opportunity to take
some of the advanced puzzles at my own
pace in those moments it didn't feel
like i was really building my skills
rather i was just racing to give myself
enough time to even attempt to build
more advanced skills super practice
helps by starting you at a higher
difficulty which also makes it easier to
rack up higher scores the main
competitive mode in the solo menu is
ghost clash which pits you against ghost
versions of your friends other profiles
on the same switch or strangers across
the world finishing the exercise first
gets you more points and the first to
100 points wins the clash it's not quite
a head-to-head competition but it
reproduces the basic effect well another
method of competing with friends is
checking your ranking which shows your
solo scores across both the test and
each individual exercise a local party
mode lets you compete against other
players and include some decent
equalizing features such as a special
sprout mode intended for younger players
still a lot of the games require some
fundamental math skills so very small
kids would likely be lost on the whole
the in-person competitive mode seem
aimed at leveling the playing field in a
way that the online modes aren't one odd
duck element to this is the use of touch
controls versus a traditional controller
big brain academy has its roots on the
nintendo ds which came with a dedicated
stylus brain vs brain maintains this
element and lets you use touch controls
and in my experience that actually seems
to be a big competitive advantage over a
controller but the switch never feels
totally natural as a touch screen device
both because of its oblong shape and the
fact that it doesn't come with its own
stylus plus it's just strange to have a
competitive game where handheld players
have such a huge competitive advantage
based on the touch-based control scheme
your reward across all of the
single-player modes is coins which
unlock outfit options for each 10 coins
you gather longer events like the full
test or competing across all the
categories in ghost clash nets you more
coins but the progress is still slow
going and will take a regular playing
regimen to actually unlock everything
like the other brain training games this
is obviously meant to be a daily habit
the outfit options aren't all that
compelling in themselves but i did get a
little smile out of seeing my avatar
dressed in a deer stalker cap and fancy
vest it's never been totally clear to me
if brain training games like brain age
and big brain academy are actually
exercising your brain or simply
improving your skills at these exercises
the takeaway of these games may be that
there isn't actually a clear distinction
between getting smarter and getting
experience most of the time i just had
to remember to slow down and approach
the exercises cautiously to improve my
score which feels like a lesson in
patience and focus as much as the
ability to compute or analyze on a dime
big brain academy and the entire brain
training subgenre of puzzle games were
never as medically precise as they
purported to be but they were always
about the fulfillment of
self-improvement not bragging rights big
brain academy brain versus brain thanks
to its new competition hooks feels just
a little bit coarser it's still plenty
of fun in small doses and the exercises
are well made and for the most part ramp
up nicely just don't take it too
seriously and whatever the leaderboards
say remember to run your own race
me